[Musique]
bonjour je m'appelle Armindo machadou je
suis chef de cuisine à l'auberge du
Manet à Montigny-le-Bretonneux je vais
vous présenter une recette de
Saint-Jacques poêlée au pesto de tomates
confites que nous avons à la carte en ce
moment
c'est le poivre
[Musique]
pour colorer
on va ajouter un petit peu de beurre
[Musique]
faire attention de pas trop les cuire
et un petit peu de pesto au basilic
[Musique]
voilà c'est comme ça qu'on la serre tout
simplement
voilà alors la petite astuce pour la
cuisson des Saint-Jacques évidemment
c'est de ne surtout pas trop les cuire
sinon ça devient très vite fil entre eux
donc il faut
cuire à feu doux et terminer la cuisson
au beurre en arrosant voilà bon appétit
[Musique]